[Music]
hello everyone and welcome to today's
webinar two years into the coven 19
pandemic what can serology testing tell
us about immune status
i am kayleigh bach of labyrinths and
i'll be your moderator for today's event
today's educational web seminar is
presented by lab roots and brought to
you by biowrap
to learn more visit biodashrad.com
we encourage you to participate today by
submitting any questions you may have
during the presentation
to do so simply type them into the ask a
question box and click send
we'll answer as many questions as we
have time for at the end of the
presentation
you may also submit any technical issues
as well if you have trouble seeing or
hearing the presentation
i'd like to now welcome our speakers
and genevieve marcelin professor of
virology at sorbonne university
clinical virologist at st pta
sao petriere hospital
john francois muscaday associate vice
president of research and development by
erad laboratories clinical diagnostics
and heidi scholes
research and development manager bio-rad
laboratories clinical immunology
and genevieve
jean-francois heidi you may now begin
your presentation
thank you very much for this
introduction so my presentation today
will be on saskov2 biological
diagnostics
here are my disclosures
and uh we will see uh during this
presentation
uh two main learning objectives first to
understand the humoral response against
sarsko v2
and then to discuss indications for
antibody testing and interpretation of
results
i'm sure that you are knowing that very
well now
but saskov2
is a beta coronavirus
this is an enveloped virus and there are
two main proteins that are
immunodominant antigens
one of this protein is a spy protein
protein with a specific domain the
receptor binding domain that binds to
the angiotensin converting enzyme to
receptor site in human cells
and
this is an initial step of the viral
entry into the human cells
the second protein is a nucleocapsid
that has that is associated with
the genome of the virus that is a
positive sense single strand rna
and
this is a
this arena is about 30 kilobases
so once the pathogen is infected a host
there is an immune
music immunization sorry
and there are some production of
antibodies and these antibodies have
several mechanism of action
first
the antibodies can
be neutralizing and dissenting their
bodies in tether with the binding of the
spike protein and the ace2 receptor
and this kind of
anti-immunity in the is can be detected
by neutralizing essay
there are three others mechanism action
of antibodies
and the antibody dependent virolesis
with antibodies can activate the
classical pathway of complement and
virulences
then the antibody-mediated presentation
of antigen
with antibodies come
combined with viral
peptides which promotes uptake by
antigen presenting cells and activists a
cellular mediated immune response
and then
the antibodies
cell
cytotoxicity with antibody of the host
cell membrane allowing natural killer
cells to target infected cells for
apoptosis
these three late
a mechanism of action are not detected
by the neutralizing ice assay
so the neutralizing antibodies
have the ability to block the virus
infection there are mainly igg and iga
and they are often associated with
protective immunity
with some correlates of protection
so there are two main types of antibody
testing first
some tests detecting the binding
antibody and these tests are purified
proterence on saska v2 but not viable
virus
they can differentiate igg igm and iga
and they are
taking
from less than 30 minutes to few hours
and there are two broad categories first
point of care that are generally lateral
flow devices
and
the laboratory test with elisa or cia
this test can detect total antibody or
igg and igm separately and most of these
tests can detect antibodies against
either s or n proteins
so there are
the second main uh
types of antibody testing is the test
that
we that detects neutralizing antibodies
this test determines the functional
ability of antibodies to prevent
infection by sarco v2 in vitro
and they are allowed to monitor
inhibition of viral growth in cell
culture when incubated with serum
and three types of this neutralizing
test
are available
first
there are some virus neutralizing tests
and there are
using wall replicating various from
various subtypes
for example
secondly there are some pseudo virus
neutralizing tests they are based on
recombinant pseudoviruses such as vsv
for example that incorporates the
s-protein of sarskov2
and finally
there are the competitive neutralizing
tests and this test mimics the
interaction of the lbd with ace2 in an
elisa format
and the ability of rbd-specific
antibodies to interfere with the
interaction detected using a decrease in
signal based on of the reported fused
lbd
so now if we look at the development of
antibodies and human immunity
after a coven-19 natural infection
we know that nearly all immunocompetent
persons develop an adaptive human
response triggering antiviral humeral
and cellular immune responses
and the
immoral response includes the antibodies
directed against ester and protein
so rbd is a main target for neutralizing
antibodies and antibodies against health
can be detected in serum within one to
three weeks
igg antibodies
can persist for at least several months
in most persons but the precise duration
of time that antibodies persist after
infection is still unknown and depend on
certain factors
on this slide
you can see that the kinetics of igg
antibodies can be a variable depending
on the severity of the clinical signs
with the asymptomatic
patients having a shorter
persistence of antibodies and the severe
patients with the highest duration of
antibodies
there are also there is also the
heterogeneity according to the existence
of
comorbidities or age
in this study that we performed in
health care workers
we look at the long-term evolution of
humeral human response after saskov2
infection and we can
we were able to show that uh overall
that there was a significant decrease in
all sarsko v2 antibodies at
after six months post infection
however between month 6 and 112 on trbd
igg level anti-ace i judge iga and
anti-rbd neutralizing activities
significantly increase
among the coving 19 vaccinated assa
workers whereas they remain stable among
unvaccinated scale workers
and finally the anti-nigg index
significantly decreased between month 6
and 12 and among both vaccinated and
unvaccinated as care workers
so if we look at now after what happened
after coving 19 vaccination we know that
the current vaccines aim to elicit
neutralizing antibodies against the s
protein or the rbd
and they prevent saska v2 from binding
with ica-2 receptors in the respiratory
tract
and prevent the infection and
illness
so a positive test for anti-s igm or igg
could indicate
prior infection and or vaccination
there is also a
meteorogenity of neutralizing activity
regarding the different subtypes
you can see on this slide that there is
a marked reduction in antibody titers
against omicron variants
with 33 to 44 reduction versus the
ancestral strain at the
d6014g
and this reduction of neutralizing
activity against omicron
has been seen across all vaccines tested
the mrna or the other vaccines
however a booster vaccine is able to uh
increase the the neutralizing activity
against omicron
you have on the right part of the slide
there were omicron
neutralizing antibodies with a booster
vaccine the third dose either with a
mrna vaccine or a neterolog boost
this neutralizing antibodies levels are
highly predictive of
immune protection from symptomatic sars
cov2 infection and this is a very nice
study showing that there is a
significant correlation between vaccine
efficacy
and vaccine-induced neutralizing
antibody activity
and even titles of binding antibody
seem to to be correlated
well with this efficacy
and this is an important point regarding
the
immunocompromised patients because
among this population of patients there
is a significant proportion of vaccine
on responders especially
solid organ transplant recipients and
patients with hematological malignancies
so that there are some color relates of
protection that have been defined
for example a protection of 80 percent
from symptomatic disease if patients
have at least
264 a binding unit of anti-s antibodies
and this cutoff is used for example for
for patients
with high risk of coving severe curving
19 patients that need a pre-exposure
prophylaxis
with monoclonal antibody such as
ticks tixa gevimab and sylgavimab
so in in this kind of populations having
an immunity deficiency linked to a
pathology or treatments and weekly or
non-responding
after a complete vaccine schedule with a
below
264 binding unit of nts
they are allowed to receive this kind of
antibodies
so in conclusion um the serological
assays to detect
um antibody is again cisco v2
there are many many tests now rapid
tests elisa neutralizing tests
and we need for performance evaluations
and to better define also the
indications
we need also for additional data on
antibodies persistence and correlates of
protections
and today there are some indications
for the use of this antibody
test
such as epidemiological studies and also
to use some cut off for
immunocompromised patients
in order to use the monoclonal
antibodies for prep
so i would like to thank you for your
attention and i will be very happy to
answer to the questions
after this presentation thank you
good morning good afternoon everyone so
today i would like to share some
our thoughts and the key finding in the
literature about the value of source
code theology testing and the potential
role of quantitative assay in
determining protection against kovid
and more
particularly i'd like to illustrate the
correlation between the anti-spike
additive response and the neutralizing
antibodies and to discuss the role of
quantitative theological assays in
establishing a correlate of protection
against
covid
as was already discussed by
dr marcela when
an individual is infected by the by the
virus there is a strong immune response
that builds up
against the different viral antigens
of the virus which are depicted on the
left uh left
picture so these antigens can be the spy
protein the envelope the nucleocapsid
the membrane for instance
and this immune response consists in
antibodies three classes of antibodies
which are produced by the lymphocytes b
which are the iga gm and igg
in terms of kinetics the
iga and igm
rises earlier a little bit earlier than
the igg igg a little bit a little bit
late but overall the uh this immune
response
emerged roughly after one week post
infection so
just uh measuring the uh
appearance of this antibodies is a way
to diagnose a a new infection and there
are many kids out there
that does that very well
um in terms of vaccination when when
someone is vaccinated the
response is very similar
except that it's directed against only
the virulent agents which are present or
which are
produced by the vaccine
and uh
in the case of the kovid uh it's mostly
the the spike protein which uh which is
the antigen used in the vaccine for
reason that we explain uh later on
so this um this uh
immune profile uh with the the
antibodies uh appearing after one week
rising for some time and then declining
is related to the
status of protection of the of the
individual either when they are
recovering from infection or when they
are vaccinated so you can as you can see
on the on the right
side ign igm peak after a few weeks and
then decline uh
quite quickly igg remained for a longer
time and after some weeks igg
are they the vast majority of the
antibodies which are found in the uh in
the bodies of people either infected or
vaccinated so they are the the the ideal
uh
the ideal uh
antibody to look at when you want to
perform a longitudinal analysis of the
human response
however regarding this immune profile of
course it raises the question of whether
the people are protected at which level
of antibodies people are protected and
after uh how long time this protection
is fading away meaning at which level of
antibodies
the the protection remains
so um
okay so in terms of uh immunity the
question which is raised by this uh this
uh change in the immune profile
is to uh how we can identify what we
call immune correlates immune correlates
are parameters which are
quantitatively
related the uh the level of protection
and this is very important to identify
these immune coils because they have to
predict the clinical outcomes of people
who are infected but they also are very
important to determine whether
vaccinated people are protected and for
how long time and that's deciding when a
new vaccine or booster dose will be
needed and that's also a good indicator
to identify high-risk individuals
depending on the
on the the level of this immune
correlate
so from the uh
the very early days
uh when looking at immune correlates
what we call neutralizing antibodies
appear to be a good immune coil so what
are neutralizing antibodies you know
that antibodies work through different
mechanism
one of them uh is to block directly uh
the binding of the virus to the cell
which will be infected and this is done
by some specific igg that binds to the
the spike protein because the spike
protein interacts with the receptor of
the infected cells so that's why by the
way uh vaccines are
making those uh the are based on the
spike protein because that's the main
target for this not rising antibodies so
of course you can understand that you
know having a high level of neutralizing
antibody can be directly correlated to
your level of protection because this
antibodies
prevents the virus to enter other cells
and this is quite uh these neutralizing
antibodies are quite
straightforward to evaluate because
there are cell based assay in which
you can measure the the neutralizing
potency of some or some sarah
uh
so the general assumption from the
beginning that was that neutralizing
antibody could be a very good correlate
and that was finally definitely proven
after the advance of the vaccine so you
can see on the on the right panel on the
right figure there is a very interesting
experiment that was done
by korean co-workers they have ranked
the efficacy of the vaccine
according to the level of neutralization
that was found
in the serum of the people who were
vaccinated and as you can see there is a
very nice correlation between the
vaccine efficiency and the
neutralization potency
in short
the more the more efficient
the more neutralizing power in the serum
of the people who are vaccinated and
that's also that's interesting if you
look at the blue uh the blue cross uh
that's uh the level of protection which
is confirmed by the the
the serra of convalescent people people
who are infected and
who are recovering so that gives a good
indication that when you were infected
then after that for some time you are
well protected against the uh against
the virus thanks to this neutralizing
antibody
so this this kind of antibodies are
therefore a very predictive
parameter of immune protection
however the way they are monitored is
quite cumbersome the essay are quite
complicated they are cell based they say
and they are really not
i mean
useful in a in a routine lab environment
so
from the very beginning there was this
the need for finding another correlate
of protection and of course this since
those notarizing antibody are
a subclass of
subset of igg antibodies it was very
tempting trying to correlate the
amount of igg
to uh the protection however
uh conversely to the neutralizing
antibody igg are not that i mean they
they are they can be quantified by
immunoassays but this amino acids are
not easy to calibrate
they are very depending on their formats
their dynamic range can vary from one
asset to the other one so
conversely to notarizing antibody it's
very complicated to give absolutely to
provide an absolute quantification for
this for this lgd
and from the very beginning the
situation looks like that one on the
left
side so that's that's another um
that's a the same kind of analysis of
the vaccine efficiency
against the level of igg
so in this paper the author have
gathered all the information that were
found in the studies in the vaccine
studies
and as you can see this uh
there is a global trend
of vaccine efficiencies versus the level
of igg so that gives us an idea that
there is some correlation but
it's really not very good uh for
instance if you compare the pfizer
vaccine versus the nova max you see that
pfizer in in in their in their uh
results induce more antibodies more
energy than x
but of course these uh these results
were obtained with very different assays
which were not calibrated and you cannot
compare very uh in a very
straightforward manner the level of
antibodies producing both uh showed in
in these two
in these two uh studies so in this paper
the author have
you know started from this version
they've decided to uh try to calibrate
the essay
and they used uh they used a sample that
could be compared from one study to the
other one and thanks i mean in in this
uh paper there were some data regarding
the uh the naturalization potency of the
different serra from the patient that we
have
and since the the neutralizing antibody
can be quantified they can be really
compared compared sorry for one studio
to the other and that can be used to
calibrate the asset so that's what the
authors have done they have recalibrated
all the data
by using a comparable sample for which
the new uh the neutralization potency
and the uh the results of this uh of
this analysis is shown on the right
panel and that you can see now that
when the uh the results are uh
calibrated with comparable sample then
there is a correlation between the the
level of igg
and the vaccine efficacy so that's
really uh one of the first studies
showing that igg could be used
as a immune correlate to predict
uh the protection so next slide shows
you a different line of evidence so
that's a study that was done on the
court of people who were vaccinated
uh it's an israeli court
and um the author have studied what we
call the the what they call the brexit
cases which means
uh the the the infection of people
who were previously vaccinated
and uh they have plotted the number of
brexit brexit cases as a function of the
title of either the energizing antibody
or the igg level and you see that in
both cases there is a good relation
between the the level the title of the
antibodies and the probability to be uh
to uh to have a breakthrough case to be
infected so again that that study uh
demonstrated that there is
there is a close relationship with the
level of iggs and the probability to be
infected uh meaning the uh your immune
protection and that's uh that's also a
correlation with naturalizing antibody
so
starting from those considerations the
scientific community has decided
to provide a way to calibrate
the uh the igg immunoassay in order to
really provide some quantification that
could be compared from one asset to
another and and the the overall
objective of which being to be able to
provide some real quantitative threshold
for this uh for this igg so
under the lead of the wh show
a standard an international standard was
developed
and what is important with this standard
is that it's uh correlated to the
neutralization i say it means that there
is a
a good relationship between the level of
igg and the neutralization potency and
it's now calibrated into a
unique unit which is called the binding
antibody units or bau which can be used
for all assay provided that they are
calibrated onto this standard and now if
we look back
at the uh the study of the protection
conferred by a vaccine
in relation with the uh the level of igg
which is produced by the vaccine or
produced by a by infection by the way
the results is given on the on the left
panel as you can see so again we see
this uh great correlation it really
shows that the level of the efficacy of
the vaccine which is expressed here as a
as a risk to be uh to be infected so one
meaning that
it's the maximum risk and and zero being
you are fully protected so you can see
the the green line indicating the the
relation between the i mean the
quantitative relationship between the
level of igg and the degree of
protection but what we have now with
this bau is that we can start
defining thresholds so for instance in
this paper the author have defined a
threshold around 30 bau for being
protected at the level of 50
and uh um a threshold which is around 2
264 here precisely which gives you 80
chance to be
protected so that really shows now that
we have some
some quantification which is possible
that
provides some idea of the risk
of being infected
as a function of the level of igg
present in the industry so in the uh
in the um uh experimentation on the on
the right side so that's uh
that gives you a more comprehensive view
of what you can expect uh in vaccinated
individuals so that's uh
it shows you that
uh
for people who were not in this court of
people who are not vaccinated uh the um
uh the title was below 10 bau
and protection starts around 100 and
when people are fully vaccinated the
title is in the 1000 to 10 000
uh range so that doesn't mean that
doesn't mean that it's an absolute value
but that gives you a good idea in the
dynamic range and in the in the dynamic
range of where you'll find people who
are protected or not protected so
roughly
india in the in
the in the area of the 10 au
you have the switch 10 to 10 1 10 to 100
you have the the switch of
non-protection to protection and above
100 which is very close to what we have
on the left on the left side 10 to 1
uh confessed protection and above one
thousand bau uh the individuals are
protected
um
[Music]
so now that's also allows to uh compare
the assays so that's a comparison
between four different assays and as you
can see so this this assay were
calibrated with the international
international standard
and uh when you're looking at this uh
this data again it shows you although
there is some viability i mean all the
differences we are not completely erased
but you can see that mostly
uh
the the the level of protection i mean
the absence of protection which is given
by the absence of
of neutralizing potency that's what
what's mean as vnt negative so it's
roughly in the 10 to 100
bau depending on the usa
and
the protection is confirmed above 100 to
1000.
so another
another possibility which is confirmed
now by the fact that we can quantify the
lgg and that that they are a good immune
correlates to the protection that you
can identify the cannot fear people who
are at risk so in this paper for
instance a threshold was defined which
is uh provided i mean the possibility of
defining a threshold is given by the
finance it's now quantifying quantified
you can see that for people if you look
at the the middle panel for instance
people will have some immuno suppression
uh
the threshold being this dash line
uh this immunosuppressed people cross
um cross the dash line only after the
second
the second shot of the vaccine so it's
really a way to look now at the people
who have
risk not being well protected and just
to give you an idea you remember this
264 bau level
shown on the previous slide that's a
number which is used now for instance in
france
for immunosuppressed uh
people uh it's considered that that
these two uh two close to 250 is the
right threshold
to get sorry to get protected
so in this context us like other have
developed new assay which are now fully
quantitative
so
this uh this assay from biola the
patellar anti-task of do a quintessence
of course has to be a a good qualitative
assay like the others so in terms of
specificity and sensitivity it meets all
the the required criteria but what is
new now is that this assay
are proven to be correlated
to the the neutralization potency of the
of the sample which is required to uh
have a good calibration versus the uh
the internal standard assay and they
have cut off
uh and this cutoff is uh for ferrara say
for instance is in the
uh you know between 10 and and 20 bau
per ml and that really corresponds to
the number that you've seen on the
previous slide meaning that below that
threshold
people are not protected
and a protection staff above that that
level
again uh this is a not absolute
threshold it's more in terms of risk
that it can be evaluated so the higher
the level higher the tighter the the
lower the risk but definitely uh um
these risks start to decrease above that
above that cutoff
so it allows you to do a different uh uh
different uses for instance uh in this
experiment we have to follow the code of
people who were either
seronegative or sero-positive before
being vaccinated so again you find this
you see the same
curve
of the immune response
a strong increase in the beginning weeks
post-infection of vaccination of the
immune response then a slow decrease
and um
eventually after a few months
uh the uh the protection starts to be
below the uh below the the required
level to get a good protection but
interestingly you see here that
people who were infected before being
vaccinated get a much better response
than the ones who were thorough negative
at vaccination showing the uh
the fact that the the first inflection
uh plays the role of a first shot of uh
vaccination
another way of using this kind of assay
is really to do some longitudinal
monitoring of individuals who were
vaccinated for instance
and on that slide you see um the the the
profile of ten different individuals and
it's very clear that some of them are
very well protected for instance they
are you know the individual individual
nine ten four
five have a very uh large protection
well above the the 1000
bau
but some others like you know number
eight for instance
we are very poorly protected
and this hasn't changed over time so
definitely a lot of attention should be
given to that
to that person because despite the uh
the second dose of vaccine
this person was not really protected
so to conclude with i would say
that now that we have this uh
international standard assay
quantitative assay can be developed uh
the level of igg is definitely an immune
correlate to protection so with the
right essay
you can determine the level of
protection of individual
of course there is no
definitive cut off so what we can say is
that
the positivity threshold is somewhere in
the 10 to 100 ba uml range
and above that significant protection is
confirmed and if you are in the 1000
range for instance it's clearly that the
people are protected
uh but that's again an estimate of the
risk as you've seen on the slide
this is just risk rather than absolute
protection
and finally
this kind of quantitative essay can be
very useful to monitor high-risk
individuals such as the
people who are immunocompromised and you
can look at them over time and see
whether they reach the right level of
protection or whether they will need
some
boosters all right i will finish here
thank you very much
for attention and uh
it will be my pleasure to pass the floor
to the next speaker thank you
thank you for that introduction uh good
morning and afternoon everyone and
welcome to my presentation first of all
let me thank you for all for attending
my name is heidi schulz and i'm an r d
manager in the clinical diagnostic group
at biored laboratories i led the
development of the bioplex 2200 stars
cove2 igg panel in this discussion i
will review the design of the bioplex
sars code 2 igg panel our calibration to
the who standard and the advantages in
using a multiplex test system to
evaluate antibody profiles in samples
from vaccinated individuals native
infected individuals both bile type as
well as variants
the bioplex sars cove 2 igg panel was
designed to detect igg class antibodies
to the key proteins of interest the
complete s1 protein receptor binding
protein or rbd protein
s2 and nucleocapsid the design goal was
to develop a panel that could
differentiate antibodies to the key
proteins that were identified as
proteins of interest early in the
pandemic
the intended use of the kit is for the
qualitative detection and quantitative
measure of igg-class antibodies against
the rbd
s1 and nucleocapsid proteins and the
qualitative and semi-quantitative
measure of igg-class antibodies to s2 of
the cyrus code 2 virus in human serum
and plasma
the bioplex 2200 stars co2 igg panel
consists of uniquely classified beads
which are each coated independently with
one of the four antigens and the
presence of each antibody is determined
separately the bioplex 2200 sars cove
two igt panel employs fluoromagnetic
dyed beads which are each coated with
rbd s1 s2 or nucleocapsid protein
these coated beads possess unique
fluorescent signatures used to identify
the presence of igg antibodies to sars
cove2
virus in a two-step assay format
rbd s1 and nucleocapsid are quantitative
assays calibrated traceable to the
who-20136 standard and have a dynamic
range between 2 and 250
bae per ml or binding acid units per mil
or antibody units per ml the assay
supports an onboard dilution expanding
the dynamic range to 8000 bau per ml the
s2 is a semi-quantitative assay with a
dynamic range between 2 and 100 units
per ml
and also supports an onboard dilution
expanding its dynamic range to 3200
units per ml this system is calibrated
using a set of six distinct calibrator
vials five levels of each antibody
affinity are included in the six vials
which are used for establishing a 4pl
calibration curve of each individual
assay an indirect relationship
a direct relationship exists between the
amount of sars
co2 igg antibody present in the patient
sample and the signal calculated by the
system the qualitative assay results are
reported as negative or positive
if any of the four antibody levels are
positive the antibody screen result
is reported as positive
this slide shows an example
calibration curve of each of the four
assays
sars cove2 serological standards were
developed for the calibration of assays
to a common unit the hope is that
standardization will assist in the
evaluation of vaccine efficacy and aid
in the comparison of data across
platforms for the for epilogical
and immunological surveillance studies
standard is a preparation of pulled
plasma from 11 sars code 2 recovered
patients collected 28 days
after symptom onset
bio-ed standardized to the who's
standard
by preparing a dilution series of the
material we use this dilution set to
assign the product calibrators the
graphs represent the
who's standard recovery based on the
standardized assay calibration the
graphs demonstrate excellent recovery
and linearity over the dynamic range
wh also prepared a reference panel for
the use and evaluation of standardized
assays this table summarizes the results
obtained during the harmonization
studies the data shows
that harmonization to the standards
significantly reduce the variance
between platforms
this table summarizes the reference
panel results using the bioplex 2200
stars code 2 idg panel based on the cvs
from the prior table the results of the
bioplex assay fall within the 95
confidence range
although only target values are provided
in the who insert for the standards
[Music]
current laboratory testing includes
acute diagnosis of sars infection
through nuclear
acid amplification tests and antigen
testing
antibody testing is generally used to
detect previous infection and antibody
response to vaccine
studies have found that igg and igm
antibodies are present by two weeks post
symptom onset questions are for
individuals
are what does the immune response look
like what antibodies are present to what
proteins and how long does that antibody
response last this is true for both
natural and infection and vaccinations
in addition
what is an effective antibody level
the bioplex 2200 cyrus cove 2 igg panel
can provide valuable information about
unique immunological responses to sars
code 2 natural infection
and vaccination allowing for
quantitative assessment of immune status
differentiation of antibody response
from natural infection in vaccines
assessment of durability of immune
response
natural infection and vaccines often
differ in their immune serological
profiles as shown by these three patient
examples each patient exhibits a
different antibody profile response
patient one generated high levels of rbd
spike s1 spike s2 and nucleocapsid
antibodies indicative
of a previous natural covidim 19
infection
the high antibody levels
may also indicate a recent and severe
covid19 infection
patient 2 generated very high levels of
rbd and spike s1 indicative of a
previous
vaccination because the antibody levels
are high and s2 and nuclear capsule are
negative this may indicate a recent
vaccination and strong immune response
patient 3 has low positive levels of rbd
and spike s1 antibodies and negative
levels of spike s2 and nucleocapsid
antibodies this antibody profile could
result from either a natural infection
or vaccination
most vaccines do not induce a
nucleocapsid antibody response as is
shown in this table
where a population of naturally infected
patients were evaluated along with a
population of samples from vaccinated
individuals one note is that prior
infection status is not known on the
vaccinated population which may explain
why some of the samples have antibodies
to nuclear capsid
as you can see in patients infected with
the native virus nucleocapsid is present
in 100 percent of the patients however
the presence is extremely low in the
vaccinated population for this protein
most likely those vaccinated patients
with the presence of nucleocapsid had a
prior native infection
the bioplex 2200 cyrus cove 2 panel can
help differentiate between natural
infection and vaccination
data collected has shown each patient
develops a unique immune response and it
is possible that
antibody patterns may have clinical
indications the bioplex 2200 panel
allows studies into antibody patterns of
different individuals
this graph highlights the range of
values obtained on patient samples for
the different populations as shown most
patients with native infection have high
nucleocapsid values whereas those that
are vaccinated have extremely high s1
and rvd as designated by the dashed line
at the top of the chart
s1 and rbd antibody levels exhibit a
wide range in individuals that are
naturally infected however the s1 and
rbd levels are well beyond the acid
range in individuals vaccinated with
moderna and pfizer vaccines
interestingly individuals with jnj
vaccine have a very broad antibody
response to rbd and s1
the bioplex panel can be used to assess
durability of immune response the next
several slides are examples of how the
immune response can be tracked over time
and how the antibody reactivity to each
protein may change over time
this graph shows the seroconversion of
someone who has never had covid and
received the moderna vaccine
as you can see
after the first shot the immune response
was low after the second shot the immune
response was extremely high the data
shows that long-term durability is an
issue
after six months antibody levels for
both rbd and s1 were down greater than
95 percent
upon booster shot the antibody response
rapidly returned
this graph shows the seroconversion of
someone who received the j and j vaccine
the antibody response to rbd and s1 were
low but steady until the person received
a booster
where the antibody response
significantly increased
this graph shows the profile of a native
infection unfortunately the timeline for
this data set is only 30 days post
symptom onset as shown the patient has a
fairly rapid increase in antibody levels
to three of the four proteins when
evaluating antibody response and
durability
questions may
arise are
what is an effective antibody response
and how protective is it
as shown bioplex 2200 stars panel can
help evaluate antibody responses and the
durability of that response and help
researchers answer those questions
a big question being asked by many
regulatory bodies is
does the
product detect antibodies produced by
variants according to the us government
variants are broken down into four
classifications variants being monitored
variants of interest variance of concern
and variance of high consequences
currently in the u.s there are 10
variances being variants being monitored
no variance of interest two well-known
variants of concern and no variance of
high consequences the two variants of
concern delta and omicron are
highlighted by the news
are the more prevalent variants today
with omicron overtaking the delta strain
in the u.s in december of 2021 the alpha
strain overtook the wild type by april
of 2021 followed quickly by the delta
variant by july of 2021
biorad was able to obtain samples from
individuals where the virus was
sequenced and identified
most samples were from non-vaccinated
individuals and those results are shown
in this table
the data showed that the bioplex 2200
stars panel can identify omicron and
delta samples only two epsilon samples
that were collected prior to two weeks
of symptom onset were not identified as
being positive
most likely due to low antibody levels
an interesting note is that the
prevalence of s2 antibodies appear
higher in some of these variants
compared to previous data on wild-type
samples which was only 50 to 60 percent
as two prevalence in samples from the
omicron variant is 79
this table summarizes performance on
variants where the vaccination stamp
status is unknown again the biotox 2200
stars panel was able to identify all
samples it should be noted that some
samples may be missed if the panel only
contained one protein
for instance the alpha variant was not
positive for s1 or nucleocapsid on a few
samples but were picked up with rbd
assay the delta variant in this table
shows that two samples may have been
missed if the assay only had
the s1 protein present the data suggests
that the presence of all four proteins
increases the sensitivity of the panel
for the variants and wild type without
impacting the specificity of the panel
the specificity of the bioplex 2200
stars cove 2 panel is exceptionally high
at 99.8 percent
with each individual assay having at
least 99.9
specificity on a panel of pre-covered 19
samples in addition the specificity is
maintained when evaluating other
populations of samples such as hama
infectious disease samples and
autoimmune samples over a thousand
samples from different disease state
populations were tested for crash
reactivity all demonstrating excellent
specificity of 99.8 percent
marker sensitivity on wild-type samples
ranges from 50 with s2 to 95.5
with rbd with an overall
sensitivity of 96.3 percent
in closing
the bioplex 2200 sars cove 2 igg panel
runs on a fully automated random access
instrument the panel is a multiplex
screen with differentiation of four
specific antibodies rbd
s1 and nucleocapsid are calibrated to
the
who 2136 standard and generate
quantitative results the panel can
differentiate antibody responses from
vaccines and or natural infection it can
provide a quantitative assessment of
immune status
as well as assessment of durability of
immune response
it has also demonstrated sensitivity of
detecting antibody response to various
variants
thank you for your attention it's been
an honor to be able to discuss the
bioplex 2200 cyrus code 2 panel with you
thank you and good evening
and good day
and now i will hand it off to the
moderator
thank you professor marceline
jean-francois and heidi for your
informative presentations we will now
start the live q a portion of the
webinar if you have a question you'd
like to ask please do so now just click
on the ask a question box located on the
far left of your screen we'll answer as
many of your questions as we have time
for all right let's get started
our first question is for professor
marceline here and this is a two-part
question and this asks to what extent
are these igg antibodies immune
correlates of other ba3 ba4 and other
newer emerging variants of concern
and secondly how do these findings or
results translate into clinical care
modalities as well as in newer vaccines
preparations
um okay
so um
yes um irish ideas showed really nicely
that
the igg antibodies
are
against
different variants are well detected by
the theological test
and is it is uh
true for
alpha beta
delta and the omegran
variants and also for the sublimages of
omicron such as
ba1 2 3 4 and 5.
so
there is no problem of detection of the
antibodies against these new variants
um
and how do we translate that into
clinical care
uh with the neural vaccine preparation
that the question is uh i think do do we
should we modify the vaccines to uh
to um
um
to increase the
the response to
to the vaccines with uh the latest
variants um
the companies are developing
this kind of um
vaccines
and we we will see if it's
it's better than the the original
vaccine
so
we we do not add the response
right now
indeed
great thank you
next question here is also for um you
professor marceline this asks do
therapeutic antibodies interfere with
serologic testing
um yes exactly
we have some
monoclonal antibodies that can be used
for
patients with high risk to develop
severe covingting disease
such as the monoclonal antibodies
developed by um
astrazeneca efficient or
so trovimab
developed by
gsk and
the the test the theological test uh
also detect these monoclonal antibodies
so patients with um that have been
treated with this kind of antibodies
have a very high level of
iron antibodies
after the infusion so um
and for several months
after infusion so so yes that there is
an inter interference
they are also detected so we they are we
we have to take that into account in the
interpretation of the test
great thank you
our next question is for jean francois
this question asks is the information
obtained with the quantitative tests
relevant for evaluating the protection
against the variance of concern
that's that's a very interesting
question of course
so first off as was said by uh by
professor martina and by heidi
um the assay are detecting the
antibodies against the different uh
variant of concerns so that's that's not
a problem
whatever the the the virus should be
infected
with uh this will be defect detected by
the uh the quantitative essay
now uh regarding the protection that
could be correlated to the uh to the
amount of antibodies that are formed by
this uh this assays
there is no there is no clear-cut um
answer here but
as was shown by uh professor marcella
when there is a high level of antibody
which means after the second shot for
instance
the projection is good against any uh
voc so that's really related to the
amount of antibodies the the problem is
that when you get close to the uh close
to the cutoff when you are in that gray
zone in a few hundred of bau
since uh the antibodies against the
since the the the notarizing uh power of
sarah
confirmed by the vaccine or by a
previous infection may be decreased
maybe diminished
against the voc if you are close to the
uh
close to the threshold
then indeed uh uh you may you may uh
cross the threshold in in terms of the
transaction and get below that but if
you are in the very high end
of the of the curve so if you have
thousands of dau then even if there is a
decrease of the neutralization potential
then you are on the safe side because
you're still above the threshold of
protection and that's really what what
was shown by professor marcella
during you know after the first shot
and and you've seen on the curve that
after the first shot the level of
antibody is not generated by the
vaccines or even the previous infection
is not that high
so here you are still
close to the the threshold of protection
but then after the second after the
boost
then you you the level of antibody gets
very high and in that case even there is
a reduction in the neutralization
potency correlated to that level of an
antibody you're still on the safe side
and you can
assess
i mean the risk the the the the risk of
being reinfected is still quite low i
mean the the protection is is quite high
so that really depends where you are in
that level of uh of iggs i'd say that if
this is high enough that's okay
you can support the decrease of the
neutralization potency but if you are
close to the threshold then
you're not on the safe side and it's
very likely that you are losing
protection against the voc
great thank you
all right let's take time for one more
question here this next one is for heidi
and it asks based on your modernograph
it looks like the antibodies level drops
off to an unacceptable level between 60
and 180 days does this mean that a
booster shot is needed sooner than
recommended
uh thank you for that uh
we should not correlate bae levels with
immunity levels each person has a
different antibody profile
graphs represent a single person so we
cannot draw conclusions using these
graphs alone
wonderful
well thank you again professor marceline
jean-francois and heidi for your time
today and your important research we
would also like to thank lab roots and
our sponsor biorad for underwriting
today's educational webcast
before we go i'd like to thank the
audience for joining us today and for
their interesting questions
questions we did not have time for today
and those submitted during the on-demand
period will be addressed by the speaker
via the contact information you provided
at the time of registration
this webcast can be viewed on demand
laborats will alert you via email when
it's available for replay we encourage
you to share that email with your
colleagues who may have missed today's
live event until next time take care
everyone goodbye
you